bonjour bonjour je m'excuse de vous
déranger je voudrais juste vous faire
participer sur une expérience
est-ce que vous avez deux petites
minutes à m'accorder donc parce que
c'est là où ça bouge et ça va commencer
donc ça va être un petit peu long vous
risquez de louper quelque chose y en a
vraiment pour deux minutes et c'est quoi
ton expérience
écoutez je vais vous montrer quelque
chose mon côté j gueule c'est parti mon
avis tu fais magicien des temps modernes
je vous propose une expérience de
mentalist c'est à dire que je vais vous
confier le dessin de mentalist vous avez
dit du mentalisme monsieur d'accord ici
j'ai fais une prédiction alors on en
reparlera tout à l'heure je vais la
mettre juste sur la pochette vous même a
vu comme ça vous pourrez l'amour accord
d'accor et leader est très simple
regardez le juste fait un petit tour de
magie c'est bon je vais tourner le dos
vous prenez la couleur que vous voulez
et moi je vais vous faire colorier
d'accord donc ça reste assez simple ça
va l'amour est allé isaac je vous laisse
moi ne regardez pas pas du tout regardé
bien tourner le dos je vais vous
demander de me colorier le t-shirt s'il
vous plaît jacques je vous demande le
colorier la cravate s'il vous plaît
jacques je vais vous demander de nous
colorier quel sens une boucle et jacques
alors messieurs dames vous souvenez que
j'ai fais une prédiction au début de
cette expérience
oui alors ce que je voudrais vous
montrer c'est que à l'intérieur des
juges chercher quelques petites secondes
et regarder le super parce que c'est pas
similaires
je reste sans moi c'est vrai alors les
gens me disent à mon avis vous avez
plusieurs papiers dedans et vous soyez
bursa mais super hot que je voudrais
vous montrer c'est que depuis le début
de l'expérience
vous allez vous rendre compte que tous
les dessins tous les dessins sont les
mêmes
ce matin quand je suis parti j'ai une
vision que vous preniez des couleurs et
vous dessinez c'est une chose que je
puisse le prédire on peut dire que c'est
de la chance puisqu'on avait tourné sur
cinq couleurs et voilà je vais là où la
chose n'a plus du tout sa place et que
moi quand je suis parti ce matin je suis
parti avec un tee shirt rouge une
cravate bleue des bretelles jaune mais
pour moi c'est jamais suffisant puisque
dans la magie on doit toujours repousser
au maximum les possibilités maintenant
vers les deux le pire je suis désolé
messieurs dames met dans la peau désolé
pour le micro qu'ils aient ou fenêtres
mais si vous regardez les chaussettes
sont vertes le caleçon et orange et le
tee-shirt et rouge
je me suis lancée il ya une dizaine
d'années j'ai commencé par les enfants
et
je me suis rendu compte que il fallait
effectivement un certain bagage
technique si on voulait se faire un
petit peu plus connaître dans le milieu
professionnel ainsi que le milieu des
adultes donc je me suis entraîné on va
dire entre entre 10 12 15 heures pendant
quasiment plus d'une année tous les
jours 7 jours sur 7 il s'appelle nicolas
l'illusionniste et puis cinéma
maintenant avec ce soir attend sur
dépêchez vous c'est un 20h à
l'université de caen projection du film
dorel salles tourné à caen comment c'est
loin c'est tout à leur 20h dvg vous à la
fac de caen
pour l'instant on va aller au théâtre
des cordes retrouver mathieu bening anne
et patrick mars pour un hommage de
théâtre un grand monsieur
je suis un très vieux monsieur
je suis né le 20 octobre 1917 à berlin
est mort le 27 février 2013 à paris je
m'appelle stéphane friedrich sl sarah
lecarpentier alors nous sommes ici chez
vous en quelque sorte
tout à fait on pourrait imaginer que ce
décor représente mon chez moi et aussi
le chez lui de stéphane hessel
alors je m'appelle lecarpentier parce
que je suis fille d'un père normand
lecarpentier
d'ailleurs je suis très heureuse d'être
à caen avec vous mais le nom de ma mère
csl et elle m'a appelée sahara je suis
son quatrième enfant pour qu'en dix ans
à l'oral mais initial cela passe sl
sarah lecarpentier dans le spectacle et
un aller retour permanent entre lui et
moi on est dans le même espace
voilà qu'on partage et dans lequel on
vous invite spectateurs un espace que
vous avez partagé puisque vous êtes sa
petite fille et donc on peut imaginer
par exemple qu ici on serait à trouville
on pourrait dans un studio au bord de la
mer chez lui à trouville
c'est une première jeudi soir au théâtre
des cordes
la petite fille de stéphane hessel sur
scène pour un portrait de stéphane
hessel où il est question de poésie et
des bienfaits de les apprendre par coeur
histoire d'encourager hurle aménageable
des apories l'infini de pouvoir lire la
poésie la prendre et la dire ensuite de
savoir par coeur qu'est ce que ça fait
d'avoir en mémoire toute cette capacité
de liberté en fait et comment encore
aujourd'hui ça peut nous parler et nous
rendre actifs éventuellement ayant vu la
guerre dans l'artillerie et l'infanterie
blessée à la tête treize années sous le
chloroforme ayant perdu ses meilleurs
amis dans l'effroyable lutte
je sais d'anciens et de nouveaux autant
qu'un homme seul pour aider 2 savoir